have you thanked plankton recently you
haven't have you no one ever does it's
not like they're not adorable there's
bacteria algae jellyfish teats baby
crabs basically anything that drifts
around with ocean currents can be called
plankton they're so photogenic that a
books just come out filled with pictures
of them but they don't just float around
all day looking pretty it turns out
plankton are keeping us all alive so
start your thank-you notes now because
here are five reasons to thank the
flight number one and everyone loves
trees trees fill the air with oxygen and
stop global warming and save the planet
so how come no one mentions that
photosynthetic plankton like these
diatoms produce as much oxygen as all
the rain forests and land plants put
together and absorb carbon dioxide and
slow down climate change oh and they've
been doing it for 3 billion years take
that trees thanks plankton number two
fuel here's another thing trees get all
the credit for fuel you can chop them
down as firewood or dig their remains up
as coal but the world's biggest energy
source is oil and can you guess what
most of that precious precious oil is
made from what a surprise
it's plankton single-celled creatures
like diatoms and dinoflagellates die and
sink to the seafloor where they're
crushed and transformed over millions of
years into oil and natural gas
sure dead trees contribute some of it
but the plankton had a three billion
year head start making them the world's
largest supplier of fossil fuels so much
for saving the planet
thanks plankton number three rocks when
we're not burning Plankton's remains for
fuel we're building houses from them
from some Paul's Cathedral to the great
pyramids some of our favorite chunks of
rock for once at the bottom of the sea
hard shells like on these forum anaphora
fall to the ocean floor and end up
mented into sedimentary rocks chalk is
basically entirely plankton so what have
we learnt
that's right plankton rocks thanks
plankton number four fish fingers okay
so maybe you can technically survive
without fish fingers or salmon sushi
muscles
any Mayo sandwiches okay let's just say
you're vegetarian the point is all sea
creatures delicious or otherwise depend
on plankton somewhere in the food chain
our pals the photosynthetic plankton
turns sunlight into food for hungry
zooplankton some of which like krill
feed ever bigger marine predators so if
you liked Finding Nemo
don't thank Disney don't think Pixar
found flankton thanks blatant number
five your face without plankton you
wouldn't have a face or legs or a ball
bladder what I'm getting at here is that
we all kind of evolved from plankton
back when life was just single cells
floating in the ocean planktonic
organisms invented photosynthesis they
invented kissing each other
they eventually invented the wand as it
is multicellular life which would
eventually lead to us okay they didn't
technically invent your actual face but
they certainly helped evolution get
their planks fountain time for a
conclusion plankton gives you air to
breathe keeps you warm at night
fuels your car puts food on the table
led to the evolution of your entire
species and doesn't even ask for a favor
in return
Titans got your back man it's always
there for you so take a minute right now
to appreciate what you've got and say
thanks plankton we love you guys
you